how's it going
so this is the first time I'm giving
this talk and so I would love your
feedback so if at the end you want to
come up and ask me questions or point
out areas it might be better I would
love to hear it so please don't hesitate
to talk to me afterwards
so my mission here today is to kind of
talk through a multitude of complex
topics and try to get them down to very
simple concepts to help fill in a bunch
of gaps that you've probably never had
to think about or many of you may have
never had to think about this is a lot
of the stuff that I personally learned
in college and while at Google and like
I think nowadays we've abstracted so
much of the stuff away that most people
don't have to think about it nor should
you really have to but there's some
benefits to understanding the entire way
the internet works and so I'm gonna do
my best to try to describe that today so
this all started when I was talking to a
friend and mentor my friend John he's
the he was a former EVP of or he is a
former EVP at which and he was one of
the first network engineers at YouTube
and he said tell me how a web request
works is literally the first question
I've asked in every technical interview
if I ever given when I thought back on
it like every interview I've ever had to
go to I've had to answer that question
myself most of the time it stopped sort
of at the surface level with like how a
web request works and and you know
increasingly over time I started getting
more and more curious about how it works
all the way down to the electrical level
so that's what this talk is about and
john was the person who inspired me to
do this
so why is it important well first and
foremost it gives you some opportunities
to identify performance areas that are
areas of improvement from performance so
when I was doing a lot of my performance
work on some of the stuff at YouTube
like the video player and feather and a
bunch of other internal projects having
some of this insight was very helpful
through identifying where things were
going to break down performance wise it
also helped me make smarter decisions
about compression and optimization and
when that makes sense for instance you
know you might you want to compress your
images but you don't want to gzip your
images when you're sending down the wire
it doesn't make sense it also helps you
triage and debug network related issues
recognize security vulnerabilities and
attacks get a sense of where your costs
are and it helps you communicate with
other engineers so I'm sure all of you
work with other kinds of engineers like
software engineers network engineers
potentially depending on the size of
your company and you know if you're
working inside of data centers and stuff
like that you may have to operate with
electrical engineers as well which is
always interesting so this is the only
bolded list in this entire presentation
so let's get started
so here is your simple browser window
I'm sure you're all very familiar this
happens to be brave I use brave I like
brave not an endorsement per se just
that's why it looks a little bit
different and we have a URL plugged in
and we're gonna load an image so you
type in a URL usually it's a website in
this case we're gonna do an image
because we're gonna keep things very
simple we're going to do just basic HTTP
we're gonna load a single image and
we're gonna you know keep everything so
it's most basic and just for the
conversation that we're having here
you hit enter it starts to load and then
you get an image right so a lot of
things have to happen to make that image
show up and I'm sure you know at the
very onset you're probably very familiar
with the stuff that I'll talk about
initially but maybe not as whenever the
stuff I'll get into as this progresses
so every web request begins with a URL
this is our URL it answers three simple
questions what kind of request is it
where am I going to send that request
and what is it that I'm requesting right
pretty basic URL semantics here and
those map into these components of the
URL protocol Network location path and
query string right so this seems pretty
familiar to everybody or anybody is
working in the web nothing too
shattering here but these are the
components that go into actually making
an HTTP request right so you have mapped
them in to a standard HTTP GET request
we're just going to talk about get
requests today and the responses that
come out of them again hopefully this
stuff provides the guide posts into
other kinds of requests and other kinds
of protocols if you're interested in
such things but right now we're
predominately focused on on web
development our web developers and HTTP
requests
so this request gets sent out on the
internet so our browser takes that URL
constructs a request object or request a
request sends it on the internet gets a
response back processes that response
into an image and then shows it in the
browser right again probably not that or
a shattering yet so we're gonna keep
getting progressively deeper into this
as we go so that cloud is the Internet
and right now I just have this morphus
cloud it's pretty cliche to have a cloud
but that's how we're gonna treat it but
really the Internet is just a collection
of networks that connect clients to
servers right at the end of the day
there's a one server who's answering
that request that I made for that image
right and we got to find our way to it
right so the way we do that is by
hopping between networks so we have our
Wi-Fi or Wi-Fi is connected to our is
we're connected to the Wi-Fi per say our
Wi-Fi is connected to our ISP there's
components like routers and servers and
proxies operating in all these different
circles and we find our way to the next
one in
in the network to get us closer and
closer to our server that's gonna answer
our requests so there's a whole science
around internet routing and and how
routing occurs but the goal is to get to
a minimum number of network hops right
each one of those little orange arrows
is a network cop and we want as few of
those as possible to be as fast as
possible and sometimes that may not be
possible because of different issues
happening in the world like maybe a
network is down an Internet service
provider goes out for some reason and we
have to route around it and so we can
get variable amounts of hops depending
on what's happening on the wider
internet but the nice thing about this
is that your Wi-Fi network only really
need to know about its ISP its
connection to the ISP and then the ISP
only has to know about its connection to
the wider Internet and yeah you know it
gets more and more abstracted away from
your original client when you start
making the request so that's the power
of the internet that your your computer
doesn't really need to know more about
the internet then its connection to its
Wi-Fi and the Wi-Fi controls its
connection to the further Internet and
that keeps going up and up with a chain
so to actually perform a request we just
need three things we need a network
connection so our connection to our
Wi-Fi for say an IP address which is a
unique address or is it isn't an address
not really unique globally but I should
say it is unique globally but in sub
networks it can be any number and a port
and so when I think about these things I
think about these things in terms of
almost like an envelope that you're
setting your mailing right so if you're
gonna if you're gonna draw that analogy
the IP address is the street address the
port would be the apartment number of
where your mailing things and one thing
that I want to make sure I just draw
attention to is that we don't actually
get an IP address right away we have to
look up that IP address using something
called DNS and that DNS is sort of like
if you were to say if you were to
prepare an envelope to hand your mailman
you just wrote on it Paul's house
right it would wouldn't get to Paul's
house the mailman would have to ask
who's Paul right and so that's what we
do here we ask the DNS server
where's assets not a matrix net it gives
me back an IP address and then we can go
out on the internet and find our way to
the server that answers that that IP
address and when we have these ports the
ports are actually where we're gonna
send data through so when we get to that
machine to that server the data is going
to be funneled into this port which in
this case is port 80 which is the
default port for HTTP
so we're really just connecting a client
to a server and making sure the port's
aligned so they can actually transit
data back and forth between them and the
way we do this is by creating a
connection so we create a TCP connection
TCP stands for transmission control
protocol it starts with something called
a handshake a three-way handshake which
basically goes like this your your
machine your laptop says hey I'm
interested in sending you some data the
server says ok I hear you're interested
in sending me some data I'm interested
in sending you some data and then your
computer says cool I'm ready to accept
your data as well so we now have
negotiated a three-way handshake and
then it's done using these small amounts
of data called packets so then we
actually get to send our web requests
which will describe how that actually
happens on a little bit through that
connection so we've established a
connection we encode our data that we
need to encode and we send it through
that connection over the wires over the
Internet onto the other side to where
the server is and the server picks it up
and routes it to whatever web server is
running on that server and then it
responds cool 200 ok I have it and
here's all the data what it goes along
with it
so packets start streaming back to your
computer and then when your computer is
sending back acknowledgments saying I
got those packets over time right and
then when we're done we shut it down so
we do a 4-way teardown where we
basically ensure that we're closing out
these connections now it's important to
note that in current versions of HTTP we
tend to keep connections open because
you want to keep those connections open
to do more requests through them so that
there isn't as we don't aren't spinning
up and tearing down these TC peeking TCP
connections frequently which is a
performance benefit
so I'm gonna digress a little bit as we
get into some of the more advanced stuff
so what we're talking about is actually
navigating a network stack and to do
that we typically talk about these
things in terms of abstract models and
the most common one is the tcp/ip model
which I've been talking through so far
at least the first three parts of it so
there's the application content which is
like the HTTP request which we designed
a little bit we demonstrated a little
bit earlier there's the TCP which is the
transport protocol which is about like
how what do we do when we get to that
machine on the Internet
the IP information which is how do we
get to that machine on the Internet and
then the network access which is how do
we reach the Internet to begin with from
our computer so they're pretty basic and
they map into these effectively so if
you're familiar with different protocols
like HTTP it's a get in a post and a
bunch of other data get post delete had
all that stuff transport we're talking
about ports so port 80 is a typical port
for HTTP and on the internet it's the IP
address and then on the network it's
actually a MAC address so if you've ever
had to debug your what were your router
you're probably working with MAC
addresses and they actually deal with
the following things these are that
these are what they're actually dealing
with so the application layer layer
we're talking about dealing with data
this is like like we demonstrate earlier
the web request is a series a bunch of
data that we're sending through the wire
we're planning to send to the wire that
gets converted into what's called
sequences which then get broken down
into packets which then get wrapped into
what are called frames and then they're
turned into bits that are served over an
electrical wire right or a fiber-optic
wire and so we're gonna talk through
that whole part a little bit so we have
the sort of implementation model on the
right there tcp/ip model and then the
one that they sort of they teach sort of
in the abstract and the academic circles
and and when people are kind of talking
about it like if you're talking to
network engineers they'll talk they'll
typically refer to things in terms of
the OSI model which has a few more
gradiation x' they're break down so they
break the application layer into
application
Taoiseach in session transport network
are basically the same and then datalink
in physical or physical means literally
copper wiring or fiber optic cabling and
so the reason I bring that up is because
you may over the course of your careers
hear people refer to things as like L 7
or L 4 so like L 7 L 4 represent
different layers of the OSI model so a
lot of the flashy new load balancing
software technology and stuff like that
or security protocol or security
technologies will say like this is an l7
compliant load balancer or we block
traffic at l4 that's all they're talking
about there's like we're on this
networking stack are they blocking that
traffic or load balancing that traffic
and that can be pretty important because
the higher up in this the stack you get
to you know the more complicated it
becomes so going back to our our
examples our back to our request the
Internet is intrinsically stateless we
send a lot of information around but
there's no guarantee it's ever gonna get
there we don't know what order it's
gonna come in we have to do a bunch of
extra work to get it to carry its state
through the internet for us so that
means a lot of duplicate information has
to be packaged in with our request and
so I'm going to demonstrate that now so
this is our web request this is a byte
stream it's just our web request laid
out with different indices you can see
that there's some control characters in
there which are new lines and carriage
returns and we're gonna basically this
is what's getting sent over the wire in
fact it's not actually doing something
like this it's encoded using two into
binary and all that kind of stuff what
we're gonna talk about that later so the
first thing we do is we break it into
chunks right I I did this with 16 byte
chunks the actual amount varies
depending on what the availability is of
how much buffer space you have and all
other stuff but for the example for this
example I've cut it into 16 bit chunk or
byte chunks
and we've got ten of them and those
chunks are actually given a sequence ID
so that gives us the ability to reorder
them put them back into order when they
land on an eventual machine and that's
really important to the next as we go
through this whole thing because that's
where the state starts to come from our
request has to be reassembled on the
receiving machine and sometimes these
don't make it right so we have two rear
equestrians there to say like we need
we're missing sequence 64 let's resend
it or have your server resend it and so
that's like the crux of what we're doing
is we're gonna we're gonna build out a
bunch of these we're gonna turn these
sequences into what are called packets
and eventually into were called frames
so the first thing we do is we put the
data down the sequence is part of the
the headers of the transport layer so
the first thing we do and you can see
these map into those those tcp/ip
versions I've color-coded them so they
match with the original tcp/ip model so
the transport headers get appended or
prepended to the data so you can see we
got our get part of our get request we
have our sequence ID we have a couple of
ports we have our destination and source
ports which tell us what the hap or what
we're gonna do when we get to the
machine the actual server like what port
we're gonna talk to you where the web
server lives and then there's a bunch of
other data that I don't have in here
there's things like CRC checks which are
cyclic redundancy checks which verify
that the data actually is what it says
it is there's no errors in the data
another interesting thing about this is
the sequence number is actually
randomized at the beginning that way
someone can't guess what the sequence
number is and try to insert their own
packets in there it's kind of cool
there's a bunch of stuff like that
happening a bunch of technical nuances
that make it possible to do this and do
this securely that I've kind of excluded
from this particular window so we're
just trying to keep these a little bit
simple but if you're interested in these
things then there's plenty to read about
in terms of how this actually works but
for the most part what we're interested
in is the ports and the sequence ID
and then we go into the internet
addressing part where we put our IP
addresses we have our source IP address
and our destination IP address then we
go one more level and we put our
networking MAC addresses around this and
this is what actually gets sent over the
Wi-Fi or over the wire the fiber optics
and what's interesting about this is
these are like envelopes inside of
envelopes inside of envelopes right so
any moment in time we can unpack an
envelope and repack it in a new envelope
and so that allows us to like change
where things are being routed you know
ads are going over the internet because
the IP address you start with may not be
the IP address of the destination of the
next hop that you're on so you may have
to like change these things around
that's what the whole internet routing
thing is they package and unpackage
these as deep as they need to go into
where they are in this stack so that's
basically how that works and the biggest
size the biggest size of that whole
thing at the bottom is one thousand five
hundred and twenty six bytes standard so
that means that when you remove all the
overhead you only get about one kilobyte
per packet right or one one kilobyte per
frame of actual data that you get to
send on the wire so when you're talking
about like a massive javascript file say
you know 500 kilobytes javascript file
it's gonna have to be cut up into about
500 packets so you pay attention to that
because the fewer packets you use the
more likely it will be to not require
it'll be more reliable it'll be faster
it'll require fewer hops per pack
they're not your hops for packet but
fewer total net hops over time so this
is why I spend a lot of time on
performance because to me it's really
important to get as few as much data
down the wire as fast as as much
information down the wire as fast as
possible without any extraneous data
because every one of those potential
hops and every potential packet could be
lost at some point and that just occurs
latency
so that final frame that has to be
encoded into binary and then sent over
an electrical wire so we're gonna talk
about that but we're gonna start going
into reverse so we're gonna start by
talking about the atom so these are
electrically conductive atoms that I
modeled in keynote they're not
particularly now particularly advanced
but what we have there is a nucleus it's
the the blue part and then I have just
one electron and so that's because in
electrically conductive atoms there's
one electron and what's called the
valence shell which is the outermost
shell of an electron if you don't know
how atoms work they're they're neutrons
and electrons and the electrons orbit
the neutron and they can only if only so
many of them can fit into each shell so
they start out with a few and then they
get bigger and bigger and then you can
only have like I'm sorry they you can
only have a certain set in each shell
and then in this case when they're
electrically conductive they have one
electron in its outermost shell and
that's how we get electricity and I'll
tell you how in a second year so by
adding poles of positive negative
charges so electrons are negatively
charged they want to move towards
positively charged poles because one of
them to break off and it flies towards
the positive end which could be the
positive end of a battery they could be
you know the positive end in your
electrical socket or whatever
and then that causes a chain reaction
where the other atoms start pulling
their electrons from you know the ones
behind them and then the negative
terminal actually picks up and provides
additional electrons into this circuit
we have is an electrical current right
so it starts flowing now the next one
I've actually removed the the atoms
themselves and just showing the
electrons so we have a bunch of
electrons flowing through a wire the
electrons are all flowing the same
direction because this is direct current
this is differs from alternating current
which goes in both directions over a
time period so it just kind of swings
back and forth but in a direct current
which is what your computers use and
what batteries use and all that kind of
fun stuff it goes in one direction and
the rate at which it's going is called
voltage right and a higher voltage there
goes higher voltage means more electrons
flowing right and what's interesting
about that is we can vary that over time
and then we can set a clock cycle on
that so imagine if these are moving and
you have one point that's just reading
them every you know microsecond or
whatever the actual amount is we can get
a sense of you can create basically
binary data right so that's how you go
from an atom to a bit is by creating a
threshold and saying you know at 0.05
volts this is this is gonna be a 1 and
anything below 0.3 volts that's going to
be a 0 you know and that's how you get
to binary data and binary data can be
converted into numbers and texts
so yeah that's basically I don't know if
that people have been exposed to this
stuff but this basic binary of
converting into a number from a binary
string or a byte which is 8 bits or
looking up how an ASCII character code
works which I don't know why but that
one looks like it was made in like 1960s
I couldn't find a better one that was a
high resolution so but so we've now
talked through how all these like things
come together and there's just a
tremendous amount of data flowing so
much data in fact that there are over
two trillion gigabytes of data will be
transmitted on the internet next year to
me that's a staggering amount of data
right and it's all going through what I
just showed you right it's going over
electrical wires and fiber optics it's
using those packets and frames and all
that networking that I've tried to give
a baseline overview of it's gonna take a
ton of electricity to do this in fact
they're predicting by 2030 in the nor in
the base case scenario the expected
scenario will be at 20% of all
electricity on the planet will be
dedicated to this stuff so one thing
that kind of shocked me is that the
carbon emissions related to doing that
surpassed the airline industry in 2015
so this is something that I like to
think about because we spend a lot of
time talking about performance and cost
right these are areas that I
particularly specialize in but also that
performance and the electricity and the
computation that we do is actually
creating a lot of emissions as well and
it's surpassed the airline industry
three years ago four years ago so that
was kind of surprised by that I mean we
see a lot of headlines about Al Gore
flying to Davos on a private jet but we
don't unseen as many headlines around
carbon emissions from the internet and
to me
I find that pretty interesting and I
think you know I think it's important
that we actually like do our part and
use fewer bytes whenever possible so
obviously like that's what I've put
spent my career is on getting
performance and getting down to fewer
bytes I think it's you know worth
thinking about
even though you know you know getting
your javascript file down on your
personal portfolio is probably not going
to contribute that much but there's many
of you who either work for or will be
working for some of these larger
companies like a Google or a Facebook
where you do have control over some of
this and you can have a major impact and
to me that's like really important to
think about is like how can we keep our
data down because we can actually like
help you know maybe cut some of those
electrical costs of it
I know at our company we spend hundreds
of thousands of dollars a month on
electricity effectively you know and so
like anything we can do to cut that down
benefits not only our costs and our
performance it also benefits potentially
the world so there is like actual
importance to understanding this stuff
and how it impacts not only your
business but also the world we're in so
if you liked this talk I want to
recommend a book I have no reason this
is my like a super endorser over this
person right like that but it was a book
I read way back in 10-15 years ago
highly recommend it it explains the
inside sofa computer effectively so it's
what I was been trying to base this talk
on is to try to get to the level of this
particular book in terms of being able
to communicate effectively how some of
this stuff works in this particular case
this is like CPUs and and memory and all
that kind of fun stuff so if you're
interested check that book out I highly
recommend it thank you
[Applause]